als in italien eine ausgangssperre wegen
des corona virus verhängt wurde waren
normalerweise viel besuchte
touristenattraktionen plötzlich wie
leergefegt vor allem in venedig konnte
man ein super interessantes phänomen
beobachten denn zum ersten mal seit
jahren stand das wasser dort wieder
sauber zu sein und fische dringend
wieder in die kanäle der schwimmenden
stadt vor
klar das war ein weitaus weniger schiffe
das fliegen kaum noch flugzeuge und
viele urlauber wird venedig in nächster
zeit auch nicht sehen
die umwelt kann also durchatmen aber
obwohl das wasser in venedig und
wahrscheinlich auch in vielen anderen
orten auf der welt jetzt sauberer wirkt
ist es das leider nur bedingt denn es
gibt eine gefahr für unsere umwelt die
auch in schwierigen zeiten wie diesen
keine pause macht und das ist
plastikmüll das zwanzigste jahrhundert
gilt als revolutionäre ära der
plastikindustrie schritt um schritt sind
komplette branchen auf plastik
umgestiegen autos verpackung und sogar
die medizin mittlerweile ist plastik
überall vor allem weil es super
praktisch ist es ist leicht
widerstandsfähig lässt sich einfach
formen und ist vor allem natürlich super
günstig leider bekommen wir nun im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert die
konsequenzen dieser plastik revolution
zu spüren denn jedes jahr landen 8
millionen tonnen plastik im meer
tendenz steigend wissenschaftler
sprechen bereits vom plastik planeten
erde aber wie kam es überhaupt so weit
dass tonnen von plastik in unseren
ozeanen landen und wie lange dieses
plastik über umwege wieder bei uns auf
dem teller
genau das erfahrt ihr jetzt bei doktor
watson
[Musik]
herrlich ist damit lange das plastik
schätzungsweise befinden sich in jedem
kubikmeter meerwasser durchschnittlich
46 plastikteile tendenz steigend mit
weitreichenden folgen
in deutschland werden gerade mal 16
prozent unseres plastikmülls recycelt
der rest wird unter hohem co2 emissionen
verbrannt oder ins ausland geschickt und
landet dort meist irgendwann im meer ab
nehmen wir mal an ab heute würde kein
stück plastik mehr in die ozeane
gelangen
dann haben tiere pflanzen und menschen
immer noch mit dem aktuellen plastikmüll
in den weltmeeren zu kämpfen und das für
die nächsten 400 jahre
denn so lange dauert ist bis plastik
sich vollständig zersetzt pet flaschen
sind sogar überhaupt nicht biologisch
abbaubar
aber wie kommt es dazu dass jährlich 18
millionen tonnen plastik im meer landen
wie kann das sein
das passiert in der regel aus drei
gründen erstens mittelbares plastik oft
einfach in den restmüll geschmissen
wenn es nicht verbrannt wird landet es
auf einer mülldeponie hier wird plastik
häufig weggeweht landet in flüssen und
so langfristig auch im meer
zweitens wird plastik auch einfach auf
die straße geworfen und durch wind und
regen kann es dann in die kanalisation
und von da ist auch wieder ins meer
gelangen
drittens werden tatsächlich viele
produkte die plastik enthalten durch die
toilette ins meer gespült zum beispiel
wattestäbchen feuchttücher und andere
hygieneprodukte ist das ganze plastik
einmal im meer angekommen zersetzt sich
ganz langsam durch zum beispiel die
energie der sonne
so entstehen winzige kleine
plastikteilchen und wenn diese kleiner
als 5 mm sind dann nennen wir das mikro
plastik und dieses micro plastik ist
viel gefährlicher als die meisten von
uns denken
der micro plastik belastet pflanzen die
tierwelt und vielleicht sogar unsere
gesundheit krabben makrelen oder auch
lachs alles sehr lecker aber in vielen
meeresbewohnern wird immer wieder
verdaut das mikro plastik gefunden denn
meistens sind es die plastikstücke so
klein dass fische und andere tiere sie
gar nicht bemerken oder sogar mit echter
nahrung verwechseln und einfach essen so
selbst beim plankton zum beispiel ein
sättigungsgefühl ein ohne die
notwendigen nährstoffe zu sich genommen
zu haben
dadurch hat das plankton weniger energie
um sich fortzupflanzen
oder verhungert sogar dann aber eine
wichtige nahrungsmittel grundlage für
viele größere meerestiere ist stützt
somit langsam ein essenzieller teil der
nahrungskette ab aber im gegensatz zu
plankton sind wir glücklicherweise in
der lage zu erkennen ob wir gerade
plastik essen oder leider nein denn die
verschmutzung durch mikro plastik reicht
sogar bis zu dir nach hause
laut einer studie ist nämlich in 83
prozent des weltweiten leitungswassers
micro plastik enthalten und die wohl
erschreckendste studie kommt von der
universität wien
dieser hat menschliche stuhlproben aus
mehreren ländern getestet und egal ob
aus russland japan oder england in 100
prozent der proben wurde micro plastik
gefunden eine ähnliche studie kommt aus
südkorea
hier haben wissenschaftler 39 weltweit
erhältliche salze getestet und
tatsächlich wurde bei 36 davon micro
plastik festgestellt bei einem konsum
von durchschnittlich zehn gramm salz pro
tag nimmt ein mensch circa 2000 stücke
micro plastik im jahr zu sich und die
verschmutzung durch mikro plastik geht
noch viel weiter zum beispiel
untersuchen wissenschaftler seit dem
letzten jahr auch nährboden an land denn
klar wenn plastik im leitungswasser ist
und dieses leitungswasser zum gießen
benutzt wird dann gelang es auch in den
nährboden von pflanzen
egal ob auf dem bauernhof im blumenbeet
in der großstadt oder im garten der
vorstadt fast überall hat man schon
micro plastik gefunden
diese reise von plastik in den
lebensraum von tieren den nährboden von
pflanzen und letztendlich auch in
unserem körper startet tatsächlich schon
bei uns zu hause wenn ihr selber
herausfinden wollte wie viel plastik
durch freigesetzt wird und wie viel
plastik ihr selber jeden tag aufnimmt
dann könnt ihr hier einen test machen
kostet auch nichts man muss sich nicht
anmelden linke sohn in der video
beschreibung micro plastic mir folgt
euch nämlich einen ganz normalen tag
lang von morgens bis abends zum beispiel
macht unser wohnort tatsächlich schon am
meisten aus wenn es darum geht wie viel
plastikmüll wir produzieren und
konsumieren ein weiterer erschreckender
fakt ist dass schon morgens beim
zähneputzen micro plastik in unserem
magen gelangt die bossen der meisten
zahlen müssen sind aus plastik
beruhigen kann ich euch aber beim
duschgel dieses hat bis vor ein paar
jahren auch noch micro plastik enthalten
mittlerweile haben hersteller dafür aber
bessere alternativen gefunden
ihr seht micro plastik hat auswirkungen
auf eine vielzahl an lebewesen und kommt
auf die verschiedensten wege in die
weltmeere und letztendlich zurück in
unserem körper
die frage ist natürlich wie gefährlich
ist das für uns bisher wissen wir leider
noch nichts über die langzeitfolgen von
mikro plastik konsum für den
menschlichen körper wissenschaftlich
erwiesen ist aber dass zumindest
weichmacher in plastik negativen
einfluss auf unsere gesundheit nehmen
können
diese begünstigen zum beispiel
krebserkrankungen oder adipositas
aber selbst wenn micro plastik und
problematisch für unseren körper sein
sollte wovon nicht wirklich auszugehen
ist wissen wir mit sicherheit dass die
gesundheit von tieren und pflanzen unter
micro plastik leidet und ich finde dass
allein schon ist mehr als grund genug um
der verschmutzung durch mikro plastik
den kampf anzusagen
kurzfristig brauchen wir effektive und
umfassende recycling maßnahmen so dass
plastik korrekt entsorgt und
weiterverwendet werden kann
langfristig muss aber die industrie
umdenken einige unternehmen produzieren
jetzt schon mit plastik freien
verpackungen bauen smartphones oder
laptops aus edelstahl oder setzen
vermehrt auf glasflaschen anstelle von
plastikflaschen
leider können aber auch manche branchen
nicht so leicht auf plastik verzichten
die massenproduktion von sterilen
medizinischen utensilien ist zum
beispiel auf plastik angewiesen spritzen
handschuhe oder auch katar müssen aus
hygienegründen oft für die einmalige
nutzung hergestellt werden
früher wurden noch spritzen aus metall
oder glas produziert die dann gereinigt
wurden das ist aber oft nicht steril
es ist teurer und in der lagerung
weniger widerstandsfähig als plastik und
somit keine wirkliche alternative
okay die nutzung von plastik wird
teilweise schon reduziert kann man aber
nicht immer verhindern aber was ist mit
dem plastik dass ich jetzt schon im meer
befindet initiativen wie wie ocean klima
wollen mit fangnetzen das plastik
einfach aus dem meer fischen und mit
stau damit verhindern dass neues hinzu
kommt eine andere organisation baut
schwimmende mülleimer aus recyceltem
plastik die mithilfe der
meeresströmungen plastik einsaugen
können und eine der wohl coolsten ideen
ist ein plastik fressendes enzyme dieses
mutierte enzymen kann die molekulare
bindung von plastik aufbrechen und das
viel schneller als in 400 jahren
vielleicht fressen also bald enzyme
unserem plastikmüll aufwendig
persönlicher mega cool wenn ihr mehr von
solchen fortschrittlichen technologien
oder auch forschungen wie zum beispiel
den plastik fressenden enzym sehen wollt
dann schaut euch gerne dieses video hier
von mir an da spreche ich über die
entwicklungen die uns in den nächsten
zehn jahren noch erwarten wenn es um
plastik verschmutzung geht dann kann
jeder von uns einen positiven beitrag
leisten eine einzelne paprika ist zum
beispiel auch ohne verpackung frisch und
ein stoffbeutel von zu hause trägt die
einkäufe genauso gut wie eine
plastiktüte und wenn man mal zu viele
plastiktüten zu hause hat da kann man
diese auch als mülltüten verwenden
langfristig muss aber vor allem die
industrie und die politik umdenken wir
brauchen alternativen aber auch bessere
recycling maßnahmen so dass in
deutschland mehr als nur 16 prozent des
plastiks wieder verwendet wird vielen
dank an merkt für die unterstützung bei
diesem video
habt ihr schon im plastik test gemacht
von dem ich vorhin gesprochen hatte der
ist von merck ins leben gerufen worden
und in meinen augen ziemlich cool denn
er ist kostenlos ihr müsst euch nicht
anmelden wollen keine daten
merck hat das gemacht damit man sich mal
bewusst machen kann wie viel plastik man
tatsächlich in die umwelt setzt und ich
hab das für ihn selber mal gemacht und
ist was ziemlich erstaunliches bei
umgekommen ich bin an jedem tag für 1,3
millionen plastikteilchen verantwortlich
und ich nehme jeden tag 420
plastikteilchen in meinem körper auf in
das ist ziemlich krass wie viel das ist
ich hatte das nicht erwartet
schaut euch auf jeden fall an bin sehr
gespannt was bei euch raus kommt ob ihr
hier seid oder niedriger als ich und
ansonsten könnt ihr euch auf derselben
website auch einen film angucken der den
weg vom mikro plastik zeigt wie das
mikro plastik vom zähneputzen in die
weltmeere und dann zum fischrestaurant
kommt ziemlich cool gemachter film
schaut euch den gerne mal an
ansonsten wie immer vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig aber
bleibt zu hause
patrick